hmmm ça les halles et mariam travaille
d'habitude en tant que domestiques dans
les villas cossues de la capitale addis
abeba mais avec la pandémie de
coronavirus cette mère célibataire ne
peut plus exercer son métier depuis
l'arrivée du coronavirus il n'ya plus
d'emploi
nous restons à la maison et nous avons
cessé de sortir pour éviter d'être
infecté et le cadam saleh est loin
d'être isolé selon la banque mondiale
près 200 millions de personnes dans le
monde pourrait bientôt tomber dans
l'extrême pauvreté c'est à dire vivre
avec seulement 1 euro 60 centimes par
jour
pourtant avec une progression annuelle
estimée à 10% la hausse du pib
j'obtiens est l'une des plus importantes
au monde depuis les années 2000
un essor qui a jusqu'à présent permis à
une bonne partie de la population de ne
pas tomber dans l'extrême pauvreté
mais avec la pandémie toutes ces
avancées risque d'être réduite à néant
sur la base de ces projections et avec
une contraction de l'économie assez
importante en raison de la pandémie
mondiale
nous nous attendons à une hausse de la
pauvreté pour la première fois depuis la
crise économique asiatique de 1998 une
situation critique d'autant qu'à
l'instar de nombreux pays d'afrique
subsaharienne l'éthiopien est dépendante
des investissements étrangers
une manne totalement à l'arrêt avec les
restrictions de voyage selon plusieurs
organisations non gouvernementales pour
faire face à la crise les états les plus
pauvres ont avant tout besoin d'être
financière et d'un allègement de leur
dette
le service bilatérales de la dette a été
suspendu jusqu'à la fin de cette année
les ce n'est pas assez nous devons le
faire aussi pour 2021
nous avons besoin que les organisations
multilatérales et les créanciers privés
prennent leur responsabilité selon la
banque mondiale la situation ne pourra
s'améliorer que lorsqu un vaccin
efficace sera trouvée et distribué à la
population
d'ici là les difficultés risquent de
continuer pour am salée